foreign
[Music]
stands for an idea
whose time is now Ronald Reagan will win
tonight what a schmuck
I think I want to be an artist when I
grow up gonna be an artist if you want
to be nothing's going to stop you you're
going to college go have dinner with
Kings if he plays his cards right
I really like your stickers my step
brother give them to me he's in the Air
Force that's so cool
how dare you a menace to you
are you not to associate with him again
what do you mean why
I think you know what I mean
my parents are sending me to my
brother's school it's heavy
in this institution you can be anything
you want to be it won't be because of a
handout it'll be because you earned your
way there
someone's bugging you what is it
sometimes kids say bad words about the
black kids who's there somebody from my
old school
did they ever come to your house what'd
you do when that happens obviously
nothing of course you think that's
[Music]
that's why'd she come here because they
wanted to kill her that's why
so and sometimes they go out looking for
Jews
so it got on the boat and we came over
here to America the land of dreams
[Music]
you just wanted to be like you I want
you to be a whole lot better than me
life is unfair be thankful when you get
a leg up you make the most of your break
and do not look back on my hopes with
you and your brother in my whole life
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
handshake okay give me a hug
[Music]